der bundeskanzler
deutschlands
olaf scholz
macht seinen ersten besuch in der türkei
ich begrüße ich
bin nie die beiden länder haben schon
lange
intensive beziehungen und wir sind
entschlossen
diese beziehungen weiter zu führen
auf militärische kultureller
wirtschaftlicher ebene
haben wir gespräche geführt
und
wir haben momentan
uns über
den russisch
über das russisch ukrainische thema
gesprochen
die entwicklung in der ukraine und in
russland
sind sehr ins ausland
wir sind
auf der gleichen seite
das haben wir gesehen
und sind uns einig geworden dass sie
diplomatischen beziehungen mit beiden
ländern
ausgebaut werden müssen
die haben als türkei
woche in antalya
russischen außenminister lawrow und in
den ukrainischen außen
in antalya empfangen dürfen das ist
ein großer erfolg
wir führen
unsere anstrengungen fort
bleiben den
waffenstillstand
direkt ihn erinnern
ich glaube daran dass die türkei und
deutschland sich auf höchster ebene
weiter
in kontakt bleiben müssen
und
wir werden in kürze
ein meeting in der türkei
strategischen konzern
ist
im import und export
deutschlands
wo da kann man zuletzt haben wir eine
wirtschaft
volumen von über 41 milliarden dollar
und wir möchten dass
auf 50 milliarden dollar erweitern
wir
wollen natürlich
unsere beziehungen in bezug auf
digitalisierung new green deal
und andere bereiche erweitern
tourismus versuchen dir dieses jahr
wieder die
intensivität
vor der korona krise zu erreichen
deutschlands war natürlich im tourismus
ein großer partner von uns und ich
glaube daran dass auch der tourismus
tourismus weiterhin mit deutschlands so
weitergehen wird
das sehen wir beide als eine gemeinsame
leinsamens reichtum an
haben letztes jahr
60 jahre türkische gastarbeiter in
deutschland
gehabt
es war ein schöner eine schöne
möglichkeit
türkischer arzt arbeitskraft in
deutschland als 60 jahren noch einmal
hochleben zu lassen
und herr sahin
waren natürlich mit ihren kroner
wirkstoff
kroner impfung
für deutschland auch eine große
die türkei hat es bewiesen natürlich
dass sie in der region eine große macht
ist
und dass deutschland auch eine
macht in ihrem gebiet ist ist natürlich
auch undiskutabel
[Musik]
ich glaube auch fest daran dass
diese
unsere beziehungen weitergehen werden
dazu gibt es die deutsch türkische
universität in istanbul
das ein wichtiger punkt in unseren
beziehungen ist
und ich habe es auch mit dem
bundeskanzler gesprochen dass hier eine
theologische fakultät gegründet werden
soll
[Musik]
uns das auch in deutschland
eine deutsch tür geschoben das tief
gegründet werden sollte ich habe hier
den ersten schritt
machen wollen und wir werden
dies auch
nach dem abkommen in deutschland und
ganz besonders in der theologie und
sehr behilflich sein da offene stellen
zu besetzen
der bundeskanzler oder scholz wird das
noch mal durchgehen und die notwendigen
schritte machen ich habe in diesem
bereich zwei personen
dafür bereitgestellt herrn
überholen und herrn partei
einige werden sich um dieses thema
persönlich kümmern und herr
bundeskanzler wird auch zwei personen
vorschlagen
und beim essen werden jetzt herr
bundeskanzler
und ich werden darüber auch noch mal
weiter sprechen
ich freue mich dass ich das erste mal
als bundeskanzler in der türkei sein
kann und ich bin sehr dankbar dass wir
diesen freundlichen austausch
miteinander hatten sie haben gemerkt wir
haben sehr lange zu zweit miteinander
gesprochen das ist ja ein zeichen dafür
dass es viel zu bereden gibt aber auch
dass es sinn macht und dass wir das sehr
kooperativ miteinander tun können wir
treffen uns in einer zeit in der krieg
in europa ist das ist etwas was sich
wahrscheinlich keiner von uns hat
vorstellen mögen obwohl man die gefahren
noch in den letzten jahren immer wieder
hat sehen können der russische überfall
auf die ukraine geht unvermindert weiter
furchtbare bilder und die nachrichten
über sehr schlimmes leid erreichen uns
aus dem osten unseres kontingents sie
alle da geht es uns beiden dich anders
als vielen bürgern und bürgern unserer
länder hängen vor den fernsehapparaten
schoss die bilder an und machen uns
sorgen um die menschen die ihr leben
verlieren um die familien die
auseinandergerissen werden um die
zerstörung die in der ukraine
stattfinden
wir sind uns beide präsident erdogan und
ich völlig einig in der verurteilung des
gewaltsamen militärischen vorgehens
russlands in der ukraine
und wir sind uns völlig einig dass es so
schnell wie möglich einen
waffenstillstand geben muss denn das ist
jetzt richtig damit nicht weiteres
menschenleben gefährdet wird es muss
sichere korridore geben für zivilisten
dass sie sich aus den
gefährdeten orten unbeschadet
herausgegeben können auch das muss
sofort geschehen aber das sollten wir
uns immer wieder klar machen mit jedem
tag mit jeder bombe entfernt sich
russland mehr aus dem kreis der
weltgemeinschaft die wir miteinander
bilden deswegen unser gemeinsamer klarer
ab an den russischen präsidenten halten
sie inne zu diesem konflikt kann es nur
eine diplomatische lösung geben und
diesem hintergrund sind natürlich die
intensiven gespräche zwischen der
ukraine und russland sehr richtig wir
beide haben uns über das ausgetauscht
was wir aus unseren gesprächen wissen
mit präsident selensky aber auch
präsident putin ich habe selber viele
gespräche mit dem russischen präsidenten
geführt und auch gemeinsam mit dem
französischen präsidenten
ich habe mich immer wieder intensiv mit
präsident selensky beraten das ist ganz
wichtig dass wir hier alles dafür tun
dass solche gespräche nicht abreißen
sollen fortgesetzt werden aber wir
müssen dafür sorge tragen dass jetzt
auch bald ergebnisse erzielt werden die
an waffenstillstand ermöglichen wir
grüßen auch die bemühungen unserer
türkischen verbündeten die zu einer
diplomatischen lösung beitragen wollen
es ist gut dass es auch gespräche
zwischen dem russischen und ukrainischen
außenminister gegeben hat hier das hilft
alles hilft was jetzt gespräche möglich
macht und das ist wichtig und
verdienstvoll
wir leisten alle gemeinsam tatkräftig
hilfe für die hunderttausenden die
millionen die auf der flucht sind wir
wissen dass in polen schon über 1,7
millionen flüchtlinge angekommen sind
dass in ländern wie deutschland ist auch
schon weit über hunderttausend sind auch
in der türkei sind viele flüchtlinge
angekommen
türkische staatsbürger konnten aus der
ukraine herausgebracht werden aber es
sind eben auch ukrainerin ukrainer und
viele drittstaatsangehörige die sich
dort aufhalten da sind wir alle
gemeinsam jetzt mit dieser aufgabe
versehen dafür zu sorgen dass die dinge
dort sich anders entwickeln können wir
wollen im übrigen dafür sorge tragen
dass die ukraine sich selbst verteidigen
kann wir machen das mit finanzieller
hilfe mit humanitärer hilfe mit all dem
was wir auch an waffen hilfe geleistet
haben die türkei aber auch deutschland
und deshalb will ich an dieser stelle
ausdrücklich erwähnen dass die
schließung der bosporus durchfahrt für
kriegsschiffe der kriegsführenden
parteien im rahmen der anwendung der
müll konvention durch die türkei ein
ganz wichtiger beitrag ist für eine
deeskalation
allen krise dafür will ich ausdrücklich
danken jetzt geht es darum das wie
gesagt ein waffenstillstand schnell
vereinbart wird und dass es eine
möglichkeit gibt aus diesem krieg heraus
zu kommen was wir uns gemeinsam richtig
und wichtig es ist hier festzuhalten
dass die territoriale integrität und die
souveränität der ukraine außer frage
stehen und dass die verletzung des
souveränitätsrechte ukraine eine
außerordentliche verletzung des
europäischen rechts und des friedens in
europa
natürlich hat das konsequenzen
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir in der
nato miteinander zusammenarbeiten
wir haben uns sehr sorgfältig über die
veränderte sicherheitssituation
besprochen ich habe auch darüber
informiert dass deutschland wie auch
andere nato staaten ihre konkrete
präsenz entlang der ostgrenze der nato
verstärken im wald die kommen in der
slowakei was deutschland betrifft mit
dem r policen über rumänien auch die
türkei leistet einen entsprechenden
beitrag in dieser situation und wir
werden das auch für die zukunft tun und
für uns ist wichtig dass wir
gleichzeitig nicht überhört haben was
wir verstehen müssen nämlich dass der
gewaltsame bruch des rechts den russland
hier vornimmt auch bedeutet dass wir
selber sicher und stark genug sein
müssen deshalb ist es so wichtig dass
wir dafür sorgen dass unsere
verteidigung gut funktioniert sie wissen
dass deutschland sich entschlossen hat
einen zusätzlichen fonds von 100
milliarden euro aufzulegen um die
bündnis und verteidigungsfähigkeit
unseres landes zu stärken und dazu zu
sorgen dass wir in der lage sind die
sicherheit zu garantieren die wir
gemeinsam garantiert wissen wollen wir
haben uns auch unterhalten über
wirtschaftliche kooperation in der tat
da ist wie möglich die gute entwicklung
der wirtschaftlichen beziehung hat der
präsident bereits erläutert aus meiner
sicht geht da auch noch mehr und deshalb
haben wir auch schon konkret vereinbart
dass wir konkrete gesprächsformat
etablieren indem wir diese
weiterentwicklung auch möglich machen
wollen dass es in beiderseitigen
interesse eine wichtige rolle nicht nur
zwischen deutschland und der türkei
sondern auch
zwischen
der europäischen union und der türkei
spielt selbstverständlich die
energiekooperation
sie wissen dass deutschland sich das
ehrgeizige ziel gesetzt hat aus der
nutzung fossiler ressourcen auszusteigen
in einer sehr kurzen frist vom knapp
nicht einmal ganz 25 jahren das bedeutet
dass wir die stromerzeugung aus
erneuerbaren quellen windkraft auf hoher
see an land und sonne ausbauen werden
unser stromnetz stärken werden dass wir
wasserstoff importieren werden das ist
eine aufgabe bei der wir auch dauerhaft
mit anderen kooperieren
müssen den wasserstoff kann man national
herstellen aber man braucht wenn man ein
so großes industrieland wie deutschland
ist auch importe und da sind viele die
auch bisher mit energie etwas zu tun
hatten auch als importeure künftig
gefragt aus erneuerbaren ressourcen
daher wünschen wir uns auch gute
zusammenarbeit
gleichzeitig brauchen wir natürlich eine
diversifizierung der energieversorgung
des infrastruktur in europa das gas und
kohle versorgung aus anderen quellen
betrifft als russland damit wir nicht in
eine abhängigkeit situation verbleiben
sondern uns stück für stück die
notwendige souveränität für eigene
entscheidung schaffen egal wie sich die
geopolitischen verhältnisse entwickeln
da sind zusammen arbeitsmöglichkeiten
zwischen der türkei und europa möglich
genauso wie zwischen dem afrikanischen
kontinent und europa oder zum beispiel
durch die errichtung von lng terminals
an den europäischen küsten die dann auch
weltweite importmöglichkeiten schaffen
passt das betrifft das gilt für die
anderen fossilen ressourcen auch das
muss jetzt schnell geschehen damit wir
schnell diversifizieren langfristig ist
das ziel das ich geschrieben habe da
für uns geht es jetzt darum dass wir als
demokratische westliche staaten eng
zusammenarbeiten unsere kooperation in
der nato ist dafür ja ein wichtiger
grundlage und ich glaube dass in diesen
tagen die transatlantische beziehung
noch einmal neu an großen gewicht
bekommen gewonnen hat dass wir wissen
dass nordamerika und das westliche
europa die europäische union dass die
staaten die in der nato versammelt sind
einschließlich der türkei hier eng
kooperieren und gemeinsam wissen dass
wir unsere sicherheit verteidigen müssen
und das was uns wichtig ist wenn es um
rechtsstaatlichkeit geht zum beispiel
demokratie und menschenrechte und
selbstverständlich bedeutet das auch
dass wir unsere regionalen
fragestellungen vorantreiben müssen dass
wir dort die kooperation verbessern
müssen müssen müssen bin sehr froh über
die gespräche die sie mit dem
israelischen staatspräsidenten herzog
geführt haben oder ganzes frisch aktuell
mit dem griechischen regierungschef mit
zu tages das sind gute zeichen für das
was wir weiter entwickeln müssen in
europa und in unserer zusammenarbeit
die eu und die türkei
arbeiten zusammen es gibt dinge die wir
uns für die zukunft vorgenommen haben
dazu gehört gehören die hochrangigen
dialoge wir wollen uns
selbstverständlich auch für die
weiterentwicklung der zollunion
einsetzen und hoffen dass dort bald
greifbare fortschritte verhandelt werden
können wichtig ist auch unsere
unveränderte zusammenarbeit bei der
migration und bei der aufgabe menschen
die flüchtenden schutz zu bieten diese
kooperationsbeziehungen ist wichtig und
gerade aktuell am fall der ukraine sehen
wir ja dass die themen immer wieder neu
auftreten es ist nicht ein für allemal
erledigt sondern solange die welt so
gewalttätig ist wie wir sie kennen wird
es auch so bleiben dass es menschen gibt
die fliehen die sich ein neues zuhause
suchen die sich in sicherheit bringen da
haben wir aus humanitären gründen eine
verpflichtung der wir folgen müssen wir
haben gute bilaterale beziehung und wir
brauchen auch gute bilaterale
beziehungen das ist ganz besonders
wichtig weil es ja in deutschland viele
bürgerinnen und bürger gibt die einen
türkischen hintergrund haben weil
entweder sie selbst oder ihre eltern
oder großeltern aus der türkei nach
deutschland eingewandert sind das ist
heute ein ganz lebendiger teil unserer
bürgerschaft in deutschland unsere
deutschen staatsbürgern und staatsbürger
mit diesem hintergrund und ich freue
mich dass wir auch in der
bundesregierung und im bundestag viele
türkischstämmige männer und frauen haben
die jetzt ganz aktiv als bürgern und der
bundesrepublik deutschland als deutsche
die politischen geschicke und des landes
tatkräftig mit gestalten wir sind wie
gesagt eng miteinander wirtschaftlich
verbunden auch das gilt für unsere
bilateralen beziehungen und wir wollen
wie wir beide schon ausgeführt haben das
auch weiterhin verbessern natürlich gibt
es das gehört zu den dingen dazu die
gesagt werden müssen auch
differenzen belastungen unterschiedliche
ansichten die wir haben etwa wenn es um
fragen von menschenrechten und
rechtsstaatlichkeit geht oder die
perspektiven deutscher staatsangehöriger
in der türkei die mit hausarrest
ausweise sperren belegt sind zum
beispiel oder gar sich in haft befinden
hier hat es in letzter zeit eine
bewegung gegeben wir hoffen dass es für
viele fälle eine baldige lösung geben
wird auch darüber haben wir gesprochen
wir wollen unsere bilateralen beziehung
nach kräften ausbauen und die gewaltigen
potenziale unserer zusammenhang voll
ausschöpfen ausschöpfen dafür steht
meine regierung und ich glaube nach dem
gespräch dass wir miteinander geführt
haben dafür stehen wir beide dass wir
das miteinander hinkriegen noch an
lieber staatspräsident herzlichen dank
für den empfang heute wird das gute
ausführliche und wirklich konstruktive
gespräch und ich freue mich sehr
ausdrücklich auch über die weiteren
zusammenhang
ich bedanke mich herzlich
bei herrn bundeskanzler
für seine worte
und die bewertungen die er
jetzt zur sprache gebracht hat ich finde
es für beide länder ganz wichtig
aus dieser sicht ist
unsere begegnung in einer sehr
freundschaftlichen atmosphäre
gewesen
und wir werden auch in zukunft
vor dem meeting
strategischen
auf höchster ebene werden wir auch hier
eine
vorbereitungstreffen machen
und bei diesem meeting
werden wir auch jetzt
können
deutschlands und der türkei
jeweils zwei
journalisten fragen stellen
und deutschland
bitteschön die journalistin und
journalisten
ihre fragen bitte
die erste frage kommen von deutschland
von engere militärische kooperation
gesprochen der bundeskanzler hat davon
gesprochen dass nato-partner
zusammenstehen müssen was bedeutet das
für sie in dieser situation wie lange
sie noch weiter rüstungsgüter aus
russland weiter beziehen haben sie da
wünsche eine gutes kanzler geäußert und
werden sie sich westlichen sanktionen
anschließen und bundeskanzler stolz was
sie ist ihnen in dieser lage eigentlich
lieber dass sich die türkei sanktionen
anschließt oder dass sie neutral bleibt
offen bleibt in richtung moskau um
womöglich in frage zu kommen für
künftige gespräche zwischen dem
russischen und ukrainischen
präsidenten und dort eventuell zu als
mediator zu agieren
die
schüler weg stellt ich möchte zuerst der
journalistinnen dies sagen
mit militärisch
was ist die zusammenarbeit in der nato
nato ist natürlich eine militärische
zusammenarbeit
[Musik]
werden waffen bis hin zu flugzeugen
genutzt
uns ja in der nato mit deutschlands die
türkei wir sind wichtige
nato mitglieder
natürlich ist
die bewertung in dieser phase
von großer wichtigkeit
was können wir zusammen als nato
mitglieder machen
unsere fehler
bewertet
die waffensysteme die wir aus russland
gekauft haben da erwarten sie eine
antwort
natürlich gibt es da waffensysteme die
wir gekauft haben
unter den heutigen bedingungen
kann es nicht besprochen werden
was die zukunft bringt
das müssen wir abwarten wie wir das auch
vorher den journalisten mitgeteilt haben
wir werden mit herrn selensky und herr
putin unsere freundschaft
bewahren
wir werden
das thema mit den sanktionen wir haben
alles gemacht was innerhalb der un
erforderlich war
und wir haben auch unsere hilfe wie die
anderen nicht gemacht haben als
nato-land der ukraine geholfen
kleine und wir haben über 50 lkws in die
ukraine geschickt und führen dies auch
weiterhin aus
meine sache für deutschland zu sprechen
trotzdem glaube ich dass ich sagen kann
die türkei hat sich klar gegen diesen
krieg gegen die ukraine ausgesprochen
und hatte auch die territoriale
integrität und souveränität der ukraine
verteidigt und liefert ja sogar waffen
und nicht nur humanitäre hilfe insofern
glaube ich muss das immer mit dem blick
sein wenn wir über die fragen
diskutieren was jetzt gemacht wird ich
glaube dass es richtig ist dass die
europäische union das deutschland das
die usa dass viele andere freunde sich
dazu entschlossen haben sehr scharfe
präzise sanktionen auf den licht zu
bringen sie tragen dazu bei dass die
situation sich dramatisch anders
darstellt als das ausland wahrscheinlich
erwartet hat die wirtschaftlichen
konsequenzen dieser sanktionen sind sehr
weitgehend und sie sind überall im
alltag auslands zu stören die
wirtschaftlichen
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten russlands sind
unmittelbar bedroht und das machen wir
natürlich alles um das zu erreichen
worum es jetzt zuallererst geht nämlich
erst ein waffenstillstand und dann ein
ende des krieges und eine vereinbarung
die aus der perspektive der ukraine auch
tatsächlich gezeichnet und unterzeichnet
werden kann das dürfen wir nicht
vergessen wir sind nicht diejenigen die
stellvertretend für die ukraine
verhandeln wenn wir sprechen mit putin
dann tun wir das immer das gilt für mich
für den französischen präsidenten ich
habe den türkischen präsidenten
gleichermaßen verstanden das gilt für
den israelischen regierungschef mit dem
ich sehr ausführlich gesprochen aber
viele andere dann handeln wir um der
ukraine zu helfen aber sie muss über
ihre eigene zukunft und dass das richtig
und falsches zu vereinbaren selbst
entscheiden das kann jemand
stellvertretend tun das wäre völlig
falsch und nicht in ordnung es geht um
die ukraine irland ihre perspektiven was
aber klar ist dass eingerückt endgültig
beseitigt gehört die ukraine ist eine
nation und sie ist steht zusammen und
zwar egal welche sprache die bürgerinnen
und bürger der ukraine sprechen sie
wollen ihr land verteidigen und das tun
sie jeden tag
ging
die zweite frage bitte von der deutschen
seite oliver mayer rüth ard deutsches
fernsehen
lieber herr scholz
ihre vorgängerin wurde ja gelegentlich
vorgeworfen dass sie aufgrund des
flüchtlings abkommens beim thema
menschenrechte in der türkei bei der
augen verschlossen hat wie wollen sie
das in zukunft machen wollen sie da die
zügel weiter anziehen oder vielleicht
sogar bei waffenexporten öfter mal
grünes licht geben und jetzt eine frage
die an beide gerichtet ist
der türkische staat will wo es of
america und der deutschen welle eine
lizenz aufzwingen die sender befürchten
dass das zu sind zensur führt wie sehen
sie das herr scholz und und was sagen
sie dazu
präsident erdogan
schönen dank für diese frage zunächst
mal sie tun meiner vorgängerin völlig
unrecht sie hat bei menschenrechtsfragen
niemals die augen zugedrückt das kann
ich nicht akzeptieren eine solche
bewertung und da muss sich frau
bundeskanzlerin merkel in schutz nehmen
das ist nicht wahr was wir gemacht haben
als europäische union und dafür
deutschen sich sehr eingesetzt mit der
türkei ein abkommen zu schliessen über
die kooperation bei der frage der flucht
migration die sich gestellt habe nach
dem furchtbaren kriegen die anderswo
statt gefunden haben wo viele menschen
in die türkei gekommen sind das dürfen
wir an dieser stelle nie beiseite lassen
und sollten wir auch immer gemeinsam
wissen sehr viele millionen flüchtlinge
sind in der türkei und haben dort eine
perspektive eine bleibe zumindest
gefunden und das abkommen das wir
miteinander abgeschlossen haben hat auch
damit zu tun dass wir der türkischen
republik die möglichkeit geben diese
großen herausforderungen auch gerecht zu
werden schulen zugang zu ermöglichen
wohnung zu ermöglichen arbeitsplatz
perspektiven zu ermöglichen das wird
ganz konkret in diesen fragen bewertet
deshalb geht es bei diesem abkommen um
etwas dass flüchtlinge nutzen soll das
ist die perspektive dahinter so habe ich
das immer gesehen dort auch meine
vorgänger dass immer gesehen und so
sieht es auch die europäische union wenn
sie diese verträge abgeschlossen hat sie
sind wichtig und ein fall der
kooperation und wenn sie mir diese
bemerkung erlauben darf wir haben
ohnehin aus meiner sicht die aufgabe
dass wir nicht immer nur dann uns um
flüchtlinge kümmern wenn sie in unseren
ländern angekommen sind sondern dass wir
unsere verantwortung auch erkennen wenn
das große flucht migrationsprobleme
anderswo auf der welt gibt und zwar
jetzt nicht nur unmittelbar in unserer
nachbarschaft wie hier sondern zb auch
irgendwo in afrika da können wir nicht
einfach zusehen und sagen das
interessiert uns nicht so lange niemand
bei uns an die tür klopft sondern da
müssen wir auch unsere verantwortung
wahrnehmen und in dem sinne brauchen wir
solche abkommen wie wir es eben als eu
mit der türkei
ansonsten ist es klar ich habe das
bereits angesprochen wir unterstützen
die deutsche welle ich habe das auch im
gespräch mit dem präsidenten erwähnt
dass sie eine freie ungehinderte
möglichkeit der berichterstattung hat
und das ist unser ziel das zu
gewährleisten
so und ich jetzt die türkische seite
darf fragen stellen
in
divisionen tv istanbul scholz eine frage
an sie derjenige wenig protest die haben
eben betont dass in der nato eine neue
sicherheitslage entstanden ist nach dem
angriff russlands auf die ukraine
diejenige war nicht da wir
wissen dass deutschland der türkei keine
waffen verkauft momentan werden sie in
zukunft ihre meinung ändern und waffen
verkaufen
gehört auch der türkische präsident hat
es eben gemacht und diese zusammenarbeit
wird ja wichtiger ich habe schon
geschildert dass wir zum beispiel unsere
aufgaben im rahmen der nsv wird präsenz
an der nato aus stanke verstärkt
wahrnehmen und haben auch berichtet dass
deutschland seine eigene
verteidigungsfähigkeit die ohnehin hoch
ist nochmal weiter stärken sollte ja
nicht vergessen es geht ja ohnehin um
eine verteidigung
möglichkeit eine bundeswehr wo wir im
haushalt für die nato rund 50 milliarden
euro aufwenden was ein großer betrag ist
und das wird jetzt noch mal verstärkt
durch die möglichkeiten die wir mit
unserem sondervermögen geschaffen
es gibt kein embargo es gibt eine
restriktive rüstungskontrolle politik
die deutschland seit vielen vielen
jahren hat und egal wer gerade regiert
hat die führt natürlich dazu dass wir
alle einzelfälle betrachten und das tun
wir auch immer wieder neu
aber die wird ja im grunde ist durch
gesetz festgelegt insofern ist dass der
rahmen in dem wir uns bewegen
ich kenne ja die zweite frage hätten wir
gerne auch noch
julia akkus auch eine frage an den herrn
bundeskanzler
sie haben gesagt
[Musik]
hilfe machen sie auch waffenhilfe an die
ukraine
ukrainische minister hat sie aber
mit doppelten standard
schuldig weil sie keine waffen geliefert
haben auch der neue
verteidigungsminister werkräume hat sie
damit beschuldigt auch deutschland haben
jetzt hilfe geleistet nicht nur im
humanitärer und finanzieller hinsicht
sondern eben auch im hinblick auf die
selbst verteidigungsfähigkeit der
ukraine und das will ich gern noch mal
sagen die finanzielle unterstützung
deutschlands für die ukraine in den
letzten jahren sei 2014 ist der größte
zivile finanzierungsbeitrag den einmal
ein einzelnes land geleistet hat wir
fühlen uns da auch weiter verpflichtet
machen dass sowohl im rahmen der
europäischen union als auch bilateral
weiter und viele haben jetzt auch mit
selbst verteidigungswaffen geholfen zb
panzer abwehrwaffen und ähnlichen
systemen deutschland auch
ja ich wir bedanken uns dankeschön
[Applaus]
hallo liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
sie sahen eine pressekonferenz von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz und dem
türkischen präsidenten erdogan in ankara
und damit willkommen bei phoenix der tag
die energiepreise sind seit beginn des
russischen krieges in der ukraine und
den damit verbundenen sanktionen stark
gestiegen der krieg verändert